hi my name is cliff hastings and welcome
to my basement
and this presentation on mathematica
online
uh today i will give you a 10 minute
overview of how to use mathematica
online
and then my co-author of the hands-on
start to mathematica book
calvin misho we'll give you another 10
to 15 minute overview of some of the
additional neat things and subtleties of
mathematica online
for you to use either in a classroom or
in a work environment or
at home so let me go ahead and share my
screen
and get started for you so again this is
kelvin and i
um so we are two of the three co-authors
along with michael morrison
of this book the hands-on start to
mathematica just to give you a sense
that you know we have some experience in
this
so let's go to wolframcloud.com
and what i'm going to do is then open a
new notebook
so i can provide you this overview of
how to use mathematica
online so if you've used mathematica
before you know it's a great text editor
this is the notebook environment you can
interm
inter mingle text in in section headings
and titles and calculations and graphics
all in one notebook if you know some of
the keyboard shortcuts for example alt
one is a title cell so i can start my
uh notebook by saying a title of my
presentation if you don't know those
keyboard shortcuts no problem in this
little plus sign
you can click the type of cell you want
to invoke
i'm going to choose other styles of text
click on
section and i'm just going to call this
first
calculations and then put another
cell let's call it a let's make a text
cell and we'll just say
here is my first attempt
now with using uh mathematica that's you
know some nice look at text
and different things you can do uh
textually but obviously the heart of
using mathematica is doing calculations
and graphics
uh so let's go ahead and do our first
calculation
i'm going to use the solve function so
capital
s on the function name square brackets
around what i want to calculate and
we'll say 3x
plus 5 set equal to 0 solve for x
run that calculation and returns for me
x is negative five
thirds now you'll notice in mathematical
online it also provides this
uh suggestions bar to say hey cliff you
can go ahead and do more calculations if
you want
but let me suggest something for you you
might want to take this output
and find the numerical values i think
that's a great idea
so it goes ahead and then inputs for me
the wolfram language that i need
to then find the numerical approximation
of that previous output of negative five
thirds
and it gives me that result of negative
one point six six
uh six seven i can't round any six as i
said something like that
uh however let's define a new matrix so
we'll say
this matrix is defined by let's do a
three by three
so i'll say three five negative a
uh let's say uh b
um eight thirds and
five and then we'll say um
how about negative six
um let's do one over c
and uh 3. something like that is fine
so when i have a list of data
or lists of lists curly braces around
those things
semicolon means suppress the output i
don't need to see that matrix listed out
but now i can do calculations like find
the determinant
of matrix 1 and we get that result
or we can say find the inverse of matrix
1.
so we get that as well uh or and of
course we can find
eigenvectors and all kinds of other
things too now i do this inverse just to
show you this is a pretty
big you know result pretty complicated
i'm not going to do that by hand anytime
soon
but it does that very quickly and
efficiently and again with the toolbar
provides you lots of different
results or suggestions of what you want
to do
also you'll notice to the left there's
these in and out
symbols and those tags are useful
because the numbers in those tags
allow us to refer to outputs and use
them in a future calculation
for example out 28 was this result here
i can copy that
or i can just say let's take out 28
or percent sign 28 and i'm going to
replace
uh a with the number let's say
7 and recalculate that
and so now we see the a you know of
course disappears seven's been inputted
for
uh the a and then i've gotten this uh
results let's do
uh something different let's go ahead
and move on to some graphics
so i'm going to hit alt 4 again to make
a section heading
and call this first graphics and let's
do a calculation with the graphics i'm
going to use
function name plot open square bracket
i'm going to
plot sine of x over x where
x goes from negative 10 to 10.
so again cap the letter on function
names square brackets around what it is
you want to calculate
curly braces around any lists ranges or
domains
this is important to know uh to use
mathematica in the wolfram language
but it's super simple once you get those
very basics
then nothing really um you know
maneuvers
from that you've learned 99
of how to use the wolfram language and
mathematica from there so really really
simple and really nice
once you get those basics now again the
suggestions bar provides us some
different options we can do next
so let's say we want to add a filling to
this graphic i can just click on add
fill
it then provides me the wolfram language
uh
solution how to do that it took my
calculation
and just added this option affiliate
automatic to get
this results
now the wolfram language is obviously a
very typical way of using mathematica
and for any of us who used how to use or
learned how to use mathematica
you know a long time ago that is the
only way that's how we learned
to program and to do calculations and
graphics and that sort of thing
but you know somewhat new is the ability
to use freeform
input which i don't need to use the
wolfram language or i don't need to know
capital letters and brackets and braces
and i invoke that by typing an equal
sign you'll see this
orange equal sign here and i'm just
going to say the mathematica
all right just visualize for me let's
say sine
x times y plus cosine
of x y where x
goes from 0 to 3. now again i don't need
to know any wolfram language to do that
i'm just typing what i think
what happens is mathematica sends my
written language to its wolfram servers
it parses my language translates that to
the wolfram language
and then provides me that results
we can also work with data obviously
in most cases i'm going to have a
set of data either from a database or
excel or something
but in this case i'm just going to type
it in for you so you see how to
work with data very quickly and easily
back in my college chemistry days i
always remember
how titrations looked where i had a
data point of how many seconds had
passed and then
you know whatever that calculation was
at the end of the seconds
so let me go ahead and type in something
that looks like
what a titration may uh provide in a
chemistry environment so again i've
typed in my
set of ordered pairs i'm going to type
semicolon just to suppress the output i
don't need to see the data again
hit enter to go down to make a
multi-line input
and then say it's a mathematica list
plot
data2 so i can visualize this data
and very nicely and again quickly it's
provided me this
set of dots and then i can use the
suggestions bar to do lots of other
things as well if i click more
it gives me all the different things it
thinks i might want to do
with this graphic as the next step
a few final things just again show you
uh
some basics how to use mathematic online
um
the built-in data in the mathematica is
a very popular
use of of mathematica again mathematic
online provides that
as well if i type equal sign population
germany
and equal sign you know population of
france i'll find out what those two
populations are which
you know you can use lots of different
tools to do that but the neat thing is
uh that you can calculate with this
stuff
as well so let's say i want to find
the population of germany plus the
population
of france and find the average of those
two
so i'm actually calculating with that
built-in data that i have found
to find that average working with units
is also very nice in mathematica
if i use control equal i get this nice
little bubble that pops up
so i can type in things with unit
conversions so i'll say
300 feet plus and you see it turns gray
with a check mark when it says yep i
know what you're talking about
with this unit i'll say 0.1
miles and let's also add one more
we'll do how about 0.5
kilometers and then once i have
my my units all written out i can hit
shift enter to do that calculation
it tells me it's 2468.42
feet but what i'd really like to see is
miles
so we see the first option the two of
our is convert to
something it thinks it might want to
convert to inches now
i'm going to convert to this option of
miles
and then i see that it's almost a half
mile with this three
things calculated so that is a
very very quick look at using
uh mathematica online so let me go ahead
and stop sharing and then i'm going to
pass it over to
my colleague kelvin mischo who's going
to provide you an overview
of some more interesting things instead
of just the basics of how to use
mathematics online all right thanks
hi my name is kelvin mitchum as cliff
mentioned i'm co-author of the hands-on
start to wolfram
mathematica book i'm going to talk about
some of the advantages of having
content and having notebooks in browser
or on our cloud
and i'm going to specifically talk more
about sharing projects
and how to collaborate with other
mathematica or mathematic online users
so let me share my screen here
okay so the first thing i want to talk
about is the cloud storage that's built
into mathematica online
so this uh as a person who is authoring
content
this lets you access that content or
create content
across a lot of different devices i've
got a few screenshots here
where i'm comparing and contrasting
but if you create content in mathematica
online
which we just saw cliff do where he
created a series of calculations
if you save that content and then log in
in your local installation of
mathematica
you can pull up that notebook and
interact with that content
and it's all very interchangeable which
is nice
but what's even more useful is you can
log into mathematica online
from any web-enabled device so even
something like a chromebook
where that device is less powerful than
a full windows or a full mac
machine because the calculations are
happening
on our server and because there's no
plugin that's needed
you can log in from as i said anything
that runs a browser
and you can pull up your notebook again
or start a new notebook or append to
your work
but the the variety of
available devices is much much greater
with mathematica online
we also have an app so if you're using
something like an ipad
we've got a wolfram cloud app it's
available on both
ios and android but the idea is that
you pull up the app and that helps um
with a you know it helps provide a very
convenient keyboard
it helps layout the notebook very
conveniently but
in general here the notebook looks
exactly the same which is
precisely what we want and on an ipad
you know the app is still tunneling to
our servers to do the calculation
and but the look of it the look of the
notebook and the authoring environment
is exactly the same same is true with an
iphone
so even on that smaller screen the text
the calculations the titles are all very
usable
if you've got an example with a slider
you can even move the slider with your
finger
similar to how how you would do that
with a mouse on a full installation or
with a mouse in mathematic online
so the the availability across
devices is very very good with
mathematic online
because everything looks the same and a
notebook is a notebook
on any of those devices
next thing i want to talk about is
publishing a notebook so this gets more
into sharing a finished
project i'm going to quickly show the
workflow of this where i'm
back in mathematica online here this is
the same notebook
after you've got a project that's
completed you can
click the publish button up here you can
give your project a different name
or you can password protect it but when
you click this publish button
mathematica online generates a different
url
a public-facing url which you can either
copy
or frame into an existing website so you
can embed the content
but when you view the page this second
url
again anyone can read this text anyone
can look at the calculations
and anyone can move the slider to do
some mouse driven calculations as well
no installation is needed they just need
to go to this url
so let me drill in a little bit on how
that works um
you can publish a notebook either from a
local installation of mathematica
or mathematica online then
as i said the recipient anyone can look
at this but
the recipient can also do some
mouse-driven calculations
when they do those mouse-driven
calculations they use the author's cloud
credits
meaning the author has a pool of time on
our servers that refreshes monthly
it's a it's a pretty um a pretty healthy
pool
of of cloud credits per month and it
refreshes
every month but that's how the
recipients when they move those sliders
that's how it works where the cloud
credits of the author
powers those calculations
and then in general a published notebook
can be included
in really any web page so if you have a
personal
project where you want more calculations
it's a good use for that
if you have an academic publication you
can include a published notebook
and the link to that published notebook
so people reading your article
they can go off and look at more
graphics or more supporting calculations
very easily or this is really nice for
course materials so
i'll talk about this in a minute but
this is a nice way to post course
materials where
everybody can look at it as a preview
and then start to use it and interact
with it
so that leads me to adapting a published
notebook where
if you want to edit a published notebook
in mathematica or mathematica online
there's a really easy way to do that as
well
so i'm going to click back here to this
published notebook
the two ways to do this are the make
your own copy
and the download button so as the
recipient of this notebook as the reader
if i click make your own copy this
prompts me to log into my copy of
mathematica online
and it copies the um it copies the
notebook into my account
and then this is all now a live and
editable notebook after it copies
so if i go in here and say two times x
and reevaluate this
you know this is all now a live notebook
again
so let me drill in and talk about how
this works as well so
if you're if the recipient of your
notebook
is a mathematica online user they can
click make your own copy
and again then they've got a copy where
they can adapt your
notebook for their purposes or they can
append to it or they can take notes
in it download is the same idea but
it downloads a full notebook and then
they can just edit that in a full
mathematica
a local mathematica installation
so colleagues friends or students they
all independently alter calculations so
as i mentioned
when they click make your own copy that
does not affect the
author's copy of the notebook it auto
copies into the recipient's
cloud storage basically
so that's really useful for course
materials and course assignments so
if you want to publish an assignment or
materials
and you know though that the student is
going to take that
and make their own notes or they're
going to read your instructions and then
author their own content
that's a really good way to set this up
and post the published notebook in
a learning management system or a course
management system
which is really nice also the recipient
uses their own licensing
so that after they log in or after they
run this in mathematica
it no longer uses those cloud credits it
starts to use the recipient's resources
and the recipient's licensing which is
nice as well
okay next thing i want to talk about is
web forms so this is another way to
share a finished project
but it's uh it's a way to share a
finished project where
you don't necessarily want people to
focus on the wolfram
language you just want them to do
computations
so let me click back here and look at
this notebook
this is the published notebook i'm going
to go back to the original
and there are commands built into the
language now
so if you're in mathematica online you
can run these commands
where instead of publishing the notebook
really what you're doing is building a
web form
and you're building all the html for
that web form
so when i click on this again a
different url comes up
so you i could send this to anyone in
the world and anyone could start to
interact with this
but instead of moving a slider for the
live calculation
what people can do here is actually type
any equation
into this input field when they click
submit
they run my same plot statement to
compare these two plots
and then they can tinker with this and
compare several different plots or
interact with this
in whatever way you like but this is the
live calculation that's built into web
forms
nice thing about web forms is uh the
recipient could upload a data set
or they could type in text or they could
type in equations like what i was doing
or just numerical values or more than
one of any of these things so
the the flexibility for what the user
can upload and how they can interact
with the calculation
um that flexibility is is greater than a
published notebook
mathematica online users also use these
cloud credits to power
these web forms so when the recipient is
clicking submit
in in running those calculations uh
similar to a published notebook
that just deducts against the author's
cloud credits
i think this is also great for personal
websites so if you want to have someone
run a series of calculations but focus
on some general topic you're explaining
this is a great use for web forms also a
great use
is course materials and i've seen people
do things like lab reports
where students upload data and they want
charts or statistics and to have that
laid out very specifically
that's a great use for web forms you
could also just do some supporting
animations
or maybe some surveys where the web form
collects some data
and then that's integrated into our
cloud storage
our data bins specifically and then you
can do live calculations
based on that specific calculation or
in aggregate you know if a bunch of
people submit information
you could do calculations based on what
everyone has submitted over time
so web forms are pretty flexible and
very useful
i don't think it's a choose web form or
publish notebooks i think they are both
useful
just for different workflows and
different scenarios
so i'd like to end here just by talking
about a few
learning resources as cliff mentioned he
and i and a note another co-author
michael morrison
uh we are the co-authors of the hands-on
start to wolfram mathematica book
we have recently put a lot of work into
the third edition and we're just
releasing that now
that third edition has a updated and
greatly expanded chapter
on sharing uh in a lot of the things
that i mentioned here today
i'm going to quickly show the pdf of
this
um so as you can see by the slider on
the right here
this is a fairly detailed chapter
so we've gone through this somewhat
quickly today the chapter goes through
it
in a lot more a lot more detail
there's a lot more of a narrative
structure of how you would
share projects but you know what all the
options are
and what all the options are
specifically
you know when you might want to do
saving as a pdf
versus publishing a notebook versus a
web form so
all this is outlined in a lot more
detail in the chapter
as well as explaining some of the
commands that i was using to do web
forms or some of the options to
maybe have a password on this or
whatever but the
the third edition of the notebook has a
lot more detail on this
in addition to the majority of the book
being focused on
the language itself you know wolfram
language and mathematic itself
and how to use it but the sharing is
useful
uh regardless of how you use mathematica
or how you use wolfram language
while i'm here i'll mention if you're
teaching courses we do have a free video
for mathematica online
so you could send this video to students
they can watch it
outside of class and similar to what
cliff did today where he started with a
blank notebook
and just talked through building up your
first calculations
that is the the focus of this video as
well so
students can watch this and understand
the basics of mathematica online
and how to use this and then they can be
ready for projects that you assign to
them
in courses in addition cliff and i also
have a seminar series
which runs at specific times same idea
where
the calculations are built up live and
students type along
as cliff talks and as cliff built up his
notebook
but since it's scheduled we have a live
q a so if people get stuck
usually i'm there uh or a few other
people
and then they can chat with us and ask
questions or
um you know if they get stuck that we
can troubleshoot in real time with them
so if you are interested in more detail
on any of this i've listed
out both of our email addresses cliff
and myself
but i will end there and thanks for
attending today
and i hope this content was useful
so it seems like we've kept up with the
questions uh in the chat
pod so far and we've run a little bit
long so
for more q a and for more questions
we'll put cliff's email in the chat pod
and probably mine as well and just drop
us a line email us we can talk offline
if you have more questions
but thanks again for attending